cet hélicoptère de combat apporte les
couleurs de l'Ukraine mais il est de
fabrication russe et datent même de
l'air soviétique la machine tient
pourtant bon et chaque jour son équipage
dit effectué 3 ou 4 sorties
de combat pour détruire les véhicules
ennemis le personnel ennemi
nous travaillons à une distance où
l'ennemi ne peut pas nous atteindre avec
son système de défense aérienne
le conflit en Ukraine est avant tout une
guerre d'artillerie et l'armée utilise
comme elle peut ses capacités
aéronautiques limitées si l'annonce de
la livraison de chasseurs polonais et
slovaque a été très médiatisé les
États-Unis ou la Grande-Bretagne ont
déjà envoyé quelques hélicoptères selon
certaines sources une trentaine
d'appareils Ukrainiens auraient été
perdu depuis le début du conflit mais en
face les Russes qui ont pourtant des
hélicoptères plus modernes en aurait
perdu plus du double